[Music]
brothers brothers let us begin
I have convened this meeting to find out
what you are doing why have we not taken
a plane in 13 years
you don't even know it is all because
the cunning and mighty T s is always one
step ahead of us okay believe it it's
true last month
I attempted to take down a plane with a
pair of scissors five inches long that
sounds like a perfect manner why did it
not work yes this shrewd TSA they made
restrictions so you can only take a
four-inch scissors four inches what yes
how could they know that a five-inch
blade is a dangerous weapon and a
four-inch pipe is no more than a child's
plaything that is the genius of TSA they
fire us at every turn
doubles you know it's the same way with
the liquid what what about the liquid
yeah we all know how much devastation we
can wreak with 3.5 ounces of liquid the
damage is incalculable
the crafty TSA they have limited
passengers to only 3.4 ounces damn it do
one of you have a solution for us to
thwart this tsa release Tariq it's like
he's been living in for here look the
TSA they strike fear into my heart with
their polyester shirts and their
disposable rubber gloves
and the the sneakers shoes they are so
clever yes if they are listless
overweight employees who don't give a
[ __ ] when in reality they are an elite
force of anti-terrorist commandos
first the brilliant TSA religion if I
may I think I have a way to triumph over
the wily TSA and finally I have a plan
to put a bomb in a laptop and it will
detonate once you pull it from it
[Applause]
sneak in here for a second I don't want
to be the bearer of bad news and don't
be the prophetic and all-knowing TSA has
predicted your plan they make you take
the laptop out of the carrying case and
put it in a separate bin before you get
on the plane
is this not the funny jokes are kidding
I wouldn't kid yeah well tell me well
since you have all failed I will tell
you how we will destroy the
non-believers I have developed the
smallest bomb possible and it fits
perfectly into a full-sized what's going
on over here what's the situation over
here okay is there a version of the
toothpaste bomb that comes in
travel-size you know what